Hey guys, I'm Trace.
E. Coli, can divide as often as every 20 minutes
in ideal conditions
Since each bacterium splits into two the math
is pretty easy to figure out how long it would
take to get to two million.
2 to the power of however many splits!
If you started with 10 bacteria, in an hour
you'd have 80; in 5 hours you'd have 327,680;
and in 5 hours and 52 minutes you'd surpass
two million.
They're pretty are awesome.
But not as awesome as you guys. Because you guys got us to 2 million
When we launched DNews and Anthony, Laci,
Pam, Nori, Ron, Michael, Tom and I thought
"Let's see how this goes…" We didn't know we'd get to 2 million subscribers
And now we've passed that.
Two. Million. Subscribers.
That is so many!
It took years of hard work and
long days to get here
I guess we're just not bacteria...
I couldn't be prouder of everyone we've ever
had on this show and
so today, we've got a special behind the scenes
episode for you.
A lot of you have been tweeting at us for
years asking "How we make a DNews everyday?"
So now we got a camera, and we filmed the
whole process.
And this is it.
We've had a few DNews teams over the years, but
right now we're Producer Andrea, Associate
Producers Sophie and Donna, Coordinating Producer
Josh, Editor Courtney, and Audience Development
Aficionado Mitch
Plus Intern Megan and of course, Me.
But we get help from other people too like
Jules, Jennie, Janet and Julian!
All J-names… weird.
Every morning at 8:30, the DNews team gets
together and pitches new ideas to each other.
Some of them are about science, some are about
what's going on in the news, or around the
world!
We debate the angle DNews wants to take and
then one of the writers -- usually the one
who's most excited -- gets to run off and actually
write it.
After that, all the Seeker teams come together
and share what they're going to talk about
that day.
We've got a lot of talented people here and
we like to find ways to work together!
Then we start talking about the titles for
the next day’s episodes -- because believe
me, we want those to be right.
A little clickbait is good, but not too much.
While we're doing that, Janet makes the thumbnail
images.
Sometimes they get a little weird, because,
hey, we want to have fun too.
And sometimes we're talking about some pretty
weird stuff.
At the same time, Mitch posts our video for
the morning and makes sure all of the subscribe
and “click here” buttons are working correctly.
Then, it's fact checking and b-rolling time.
Sophie and Donna look at scripts, and try
and tell a story with the b-roll you're seeing
and make sure the facts are straight.
If they're not, we talk about it and try and
find the right ones.
B-Roll are pictures, videos, animations, papers,
headlines, anything that goes over the top
of our hosts when we're telling our science-
stories.
Julian was in the office when we shot this,
but he lives in LA; so do Crystal, Ian and Amy!
Natalia and Sapna live in New York and visit
once in awhile to help out where they can.
We all write our own scripts, but sometimes
we share.
Before we shoot, we table read.
This is when we read the script out loud to
see how it sounds and rewrite it if we need
to, so everything makes sense.
Once we have a good script, the team heads
upstairs to Studio A!
Matt, Balta or Ciarra will shoot our video
for us
[Balta] Julian, can I get a mic check?
[Julian] Mic check one two one two. There's officially only one thing cooler
than giant robots
and then we take it back down and we give it to Courtney.
The real magic happens when all the elements
come together in the editing room.
Courtney is our rockstar editor.
He also makes some of the animations and helps
make us all look good.
He's editing this video right now!
Hi, Courtney!
Once it's edited, and Andrea and the APs look
make sure it looks good, Mitch gets it ready
to publish.
And we start it all over again.
We have made over 2600 videos for you, and you all
showed up.
Subscribing Two.
Million. Times! And
I don't think we're ever gonna get over that!
So thank you.
And thank you to everyone who ever appeared,
or worked with us to make DNews, here for you
every day.
We love you.
We do this for you.
And we're not going to stop doing it anytime soon.
We did it guys!
[CHEERING]